[Musique]
je suis andré - 1 je suis clarinettiste
et saxophoniste à leur caisse
symphonique de montréal
mon père musicien gilles - 1 vient d'une
famille de musiciens
mon père était 46 ans alors qu'elle
symphonie de montréal il accueillait le
quatuor - avec mes deux frères dont on a
fait beaucoup de tournées on a joué
énormément les valeurs que mon père
jumeaux transmises sont l' enthousiasme
sur tous les plans partir mais au niveau
de la musique et la persévérance la
persévérance pour ne jamais lâcher
monsieur encore que je faisais des sept
à huit heures de pratique par jour dès
l'âge de 12 ans mon père ce maniaques de
technologie a fait installer des
intercom dans la maison un peu partout
donc quand je travaillais mon instrument
j'avais 12 ans 13 ans on m'a donné j'en
entendais attention andré troisième
mesure d'incendier le consulat pratiquer
attention à dre 5e système 6e mesure
c'est un seul bémol et c'est alors un
moment donné quand tu entends des
retards comme quelquefois obstinant l'os
c'est un peu tard elle j'avais du fon du
moins de fans le professeur gilles - mon
père continuer à enseigner sur la scène
dans les répétitions et dans les
concerts la majorité du temps mon père
d'à côté de moi soit l'éclair la basse
au saxophone à lattes et en train de
jouer peut mener surtout un petit coup
du nüvifone se retrouvent et ralentit a
plus doux j'ai appris énormément à le
mime un regard d'un j'ai appris beaucoup
parce qu'il se faisait moi je t'ai
impose une question je voulais savoir je
voulais comprendre in the trail of fame
satrapes qui joue
[Musique]
la famille pour moi c'est un incubateur
total sur tous les plans et en bon
québécois je considère ça comme un peu
comme une l'image d'un slingshot qui te
propulse vers le futur
[Musique]